well welcome everyone to the lotteries
and democracy conference I'm generously
sponsored by Yale isps um we know that
many of you have traveled great
distances from uh Europe and the other
uh side of the country to be here and
we're really really happy um to have you
here so I'm going to to begin um by
presenting um work uh from a book that
myself and Brenda van who's uh over
there um are writing on the historical
uses of lotteries throughout uh cases in
Europe but I'm first going to start
broader by giving you a motivation so if
you haven't noticed democracy is in
crisis right or at least this is a
pervasive narrative both in Academia and
in the policy sphere um this is very
much the case in America but also in
Western democracies in Europe all over
the place right so we think that
democracy is
broken and increasingly um there's lots
of reasons why right um the rise of
extremism radicalism in politics the
decline of parties um strong parties and
kind of traditional party membership
campaign Finance means that elections
are increasingly bought by wealthy
Elites often kind of non-political
Elites there's a lot of corruption um
there's increasingly Democratic
backsliding although we're kind of
arguing about when where high and when
where why and how to define it and also
declining trust in institutions so
across the world we're seeing people
don't have trust in government they
don't have trust in politic itics they
don't have trust in democracy and I'm
going to argue that the real problem is
that voters neither feel included nor
represented in a system that's
increasingly dominated by Elites so
everyday voters are are increasingly set
apart from democracy okay so there are
lots of ways to fix all of these
problems but how do we fix this last one
lotteries increasingly have been
advocated as a solution right and so
these are all kind of recent headlines
can randomly selected citizens govern
better than elected officials should we
give power to ordinary people voting
undermines the will of the people it's
time to replace it with sortition okay
and just in case you think that this is
just kind of a popular topic for op-eds
you know it's easy to throw out
sortition and lres but you know maybe
this isn't a real policy idea these are
happening all over the world right so
deliberative institutions uh bodies that
are selecting random people to have an
active role in policymaking sometimes
consultative sometimes advisory are
happening all over the world and have
been happening for quite a long time so
that's Belgium in 2011 Paris recently in
2023 East Belgium Ireland a lot of
democracies are now innovating by
selecting citizens and bringing them
into policy typically paired with
deliberative
democracy okay and so what's interesting
um and we think you know all of these uh
Innovations are great but Bren and I set
out to write a book that's very much in
the historical political economy
tradition right and so our book which is
going to come out as a Cambridge
elements in political economy it's
called lotteries and democracy we are
chose to look back in time at all of the
cases that uh throughout history where
actually governing bodies use lotteries
in their standing assemblies and the
nice thing is that we can use the
historical cases to give us actual
empirical data on how these worked how
these functioned what worked what didn't
why were they put in place and why were
they dismantled and hopefully this can
help inform the use of lotteries in
permanent governing assemblies um today
um and in the book I'm not going to
present the whole book today I'm just
going to give you kind of a a really fun
chapter but in the book we assess kind
of whether Lottery improved
representation and prevented Elite
capture these are kind of the two main
reasons why um we advocate for lotteries
or why policy makers are advocating for
lotteries and we also look at things
like implementation which is often
missed in these kind of highlevel opets
right so screening auditing what's the
composition of the pool are there any
selection effects that we need to um
deal
with and so today I'm going to um kind
of uh quickly review the motivation for
why kind of historical um policy makers
and modern policy makers want to turn to
lotteries and then we're going to look
at a natural experiment of uh
deliberative committees in Denmark
Denmark wrote their constitution in
deliberative committees and so we're
going to look to the past to get kind of
cool results um about Denmark um and
then um uh then I'll
conclude okay so definition at least you
know I told all presenters to uh Define
their terms because we all use kind of
similar terminology but uh just to make
sure we're on the same page so we're
talking when we talk about lotteries
we're talking about the selection of
political Representatives by
Lottery sometimes this is called
sortition you can call this lcrac
selection you can call this selection by
lot but note that most modern um uses of
lotteries involve some sort of
stratified random sampling right so
we're trying to choose a representative
snapshot of society but we are waiting
the random sampling on things like
gender geographic location
Etc um why do you select people by
Lottery it improves representation and
equalizes access to power so people that
are not Elite have a chance to um be at
the table it's anti-corruption and it
kind of prevents Elite capture um you
can't buy off at least not before the
election you can't buy off someone if
you don't know who's going to kind of be
chosen um same with uh campaign Finance
it eliminates the need for campaign
Finance if you're choosing officials by
Lottery um and so these are some of the
reasons why we might want to use
lotteries in Democratic uh governance
right but what's really great and this
is also kind of a preface the entire
conference is that lotteries can be used
to select a wide range of democratic
institutions and in many different ways
so for you political scientists that
study kind of comparative institutions
it's like electoral law you can slice
and dice random selection at different
levels you can make it permanent you can
make it not permanent you can have
hybrid systems where you have a
sortition chamber and an elected chamber
there's lots of really interesting ways
to incorporate lotteries in Democratic
governance and that is actually the
motivation behind this conference today
you're going to see many many ways to
use lotteries and ways that we think uh
can improve um
democracy yeah c yeah
yeah should be choosing itself right so
would choose
that
question exam intermate
step directly
whatever yeah exactly Co says I love
your questions because our book answers
both of those I'm not kidding um so the
first are lotteries I'm going to
rephrase it are lotteries a stable
equilibrium yeah Alan J have a two
finger yeah great idea Alan thank you
coess please introduce yourself
okay great thank you Costas great
questions so uh one are lotteries a
stable equilibrium uh and we actually
show in the book that lotteries and this
is not a a chapter that I'm going to
present but it relates the roles of
parties I'm going to discuss the role of
parties in this historical case quite a
bit uh it is the case that we found
historically lotteries work best kind of
in new democracies in unstable
environments where you don't have strong
parties to control selection so it's
kind of a rule that ever everyone can
agree upon to organize the society
because it's fair right lotteries are
fair they're irrational you know it's
not the the strongest or someone from
this part of the Italian city states
controlling you know the currency uh we
like Choosing by Lottery however we show
and actually the third Republic in
France is a great um example of this we
have a JP in a world Politics on this
that showed that parties were fine with
lotteries for decades while they were
weak as soon as parties got strong you
want to be able to choose access to
committees you want to be able to choose
everything so they take them away and we
argue in the book that this is actually
important to realize that it's not the
case that parties especially strong
parties you know hundreds of years late
thousands of years later right um are
won't necessarily allow this rule to
kind of supplant them and so in the
panel we're going to talk about uh the
relationship um between parties and
lcrac and is it going to be a productive
relationship or not so no it's not a
stable equilibrium at least not what we
can tell from the historical cases and
then we do in the book study what we
call Lottery based procedures um which
is where you're selecting um you're
using a two-stage process you split the
chamber into random groups those random
groups then elect a representative so
you don't choose the representative by
Lottery but you choose the groups by
Lottery and then they elect the person
and even that like kind of intermediate
step we show improves representation and
gets people onto committees that
wouldn't have before so even a little
bit of Lottery helps but I'll go back to
that in a second great questions though
coost great to have you here
okay so you can um uh lotteries can be
used to select a wide range of uh
Democratic institutions and they have
been right so the deliberative wave and
what's interesting is you know last
night at dinner we were kind of
comparing notes like oh have you heard
about the Paris one oh have you heard
about Milan is doing now deliberate
democracy have you heard about you know
what's going on in New York or
California this is such a burgeoning
field that this is actually outdated so
this is this is the oecd keeping track
of all these kind of deliberative
initiatives and again deliberative
democracy uses lotteries to choose the
citizens that are involved in the debate
coming together to kind of debate policy
and then provide recommendations this is
only till 2021 but as you see you know
we're at the beginning of a very steep
incline so all of these institutions are
something we really need to pay
attention to right now what's
interesting is that so most of these are
involving citizens although there are
some exceptions Paris and Belgium are
exceptions where they're incorporating
po policians to work with citizens um in
kind of these liberal committees but
most of these are citizens and a lot of
our academic research are focusing on
whether everyday people learn have
positive participation uh change their
minds you know have more trust in
Government after participating but
Brendon and I are actually interested in
the historical cases where we're at
higher levels with permanent governing
assemblies with actual politicians right
and so that's what our book is focused
on um and prior research also sometimes
is a bit kind of prescriptive and
hypothetical which is great we need
normative theorists and philosophers
thinking about you know the the core
definitions of democracy but Brendan and
I are empiricists and so we think that
we can use kind of um real data and
statistical analysis to hope hopefully
shed light on how lotteries work at very
high levels right and um high levels of
decision- making with professional
politicians with political parties we
don't necessarily think that some of the
great findings from citizens assemblies
would transfer up and so for political
science professors all of you political
science professors are nodding if you've
ever dealt with politician
like these might be the slowest upd and
so our book looks at politicians high
levels with actual governing Stakes so
they were choosing the currency they
were uh choosing the uh the budget how
the budget would be allocated in France
they were writing the
Constitution okay and uh costos your um
your uh Lottery based procedures show up
in the book they show up in the 19th
century French case um the cases that we
look at we look at um a lot of different
historical cases that each Ed lotteries
in a different way so the book is is
pretty expansive we look at ancient
Athens which was you know more of a
autocracy where they're actually
selecting the officials we look at
Medieval Italy where they um chose the
standard Bearer in Florence they were
choosing again economic kind of leaders
Denmark and France um we look at
constitutions so France and Denmark
wrote their constitutions in
deliberative groups like you know kind
of mimicking the citizens assemblies
that have provided advisory Powers but
again these are politicians writing the
Constitution um and then the lottery
based procedures in 19th cental Europe
which is this two stage selecting
committees so I'm going to talk about
Denmark today but importantly our book
shows that there's a lot of different
ways to incorporate lotteries and again
our big findings are that generally they
do improve representation if you can
keep
them um okay I kind of went over this so
I'll go quickly um but we do overall we
do find that kind of across the cases it
does lotteries do improve representation
but it also depends on the pool so one
thing that's kind of missing from all of
these policy makers and all these op-eds
saying we should go back to sortition if
you want to undermine lotteries you mess
with the pool that they're originally
chosen from and that's what greased it
right so ancient Athens the pool was
restrictive it was not everyone in the
poly you know it was effectively Elite
so if you restrict the pool and then
randomly select you don't get the
necessarily the benefits of increased
representation although it can still be
kind of anti-corruption right but so we
need to take a step back and that's some
of the projects I'm working on this year
while I'm visiting Yale to think about
self- selection to lotteries and think
about how to make the pool expansive but
also tractable to kind of scale up right
yeah
Kevin
representan groups that are selected
will look more like the body yeah and in
particular like trying to think about
groups that would not normally be in
politics if you know typical Elites and
elections were were in place yeah um
anyway so pay attention to the pool
right it's again you can have a great
policy but if you if you mess with the
step before the policy it can undermine
the benefits of the policy um yeah it
does pres prevent Elite capture but
strong parties will dismantle lotteries
at least in the night in in Europe
that's what happened and yes we can
learn from implementation so things like
screening auditing um you know giving uh
individual Representatives chosen by
Lottery help and support all of that
would be important if you actually want
to bring lotteries up to governing
assemblies but anyway so that's um kind
of the preview of the findings of the
book but today um for the next 15
minutes or so I'm going to talk about
whether a historical case can teach us
about deliberative committees and
deliberative committees are when you're
kind of bringing citizens and
politicians to uh debate discuss and
make policy recommendations um but
policy recommendations that uh will
influence policy and are uh more
advisory so we're going to look at the
creation of the June constitution in
Denmark this is the Constitution that
governs Denmark to this day so if we're
thinking about high stakes this was not
a temporary document they wrote the this
document existed it's been amended of
course but in these deliberative groups
and we're going to exploit a natural
experiment um that created these groups
we're going to see if they did anything
and we're going to measure whether they
did anything by looking at voting on
Constitutional Amendments so did people
get more democratic as they deliberated
into this groups and we te we test
whether kind of this group assignment
thinking of this group assignment as a
treatment um affected uh your
legislative behavior and another great
thing about this case is that obviously
we have no survey measures self-reported
did you have a great time Danish
politicians the 19th century delivering
these groups we can't do that but we
have what's even better which is we have
the votes which would be consequential
right you can say you had a great time
in a deliberative exercise and then not
change your mind your behavior or your
attitudes right and I'm not saying
that's happening in modern day say and
assemblies but the nice thing is that we
have actual costly outcomes to measure
using this historical
case and then um we're kind of speaking
to theories about deliberation in in
mixed groups this is a very short list
um but you know there have been mixed
findings sometimes you think that if you
get into deliberative groups you're
exposed to different viewpoints and you
moderate you learn you become less
polarized less cohesive we've had
experimental work show this we've had
observational work show this but it's
also the case that you know exposures to
different viewpoints might reinforce
your existing opinions right you might
double down or just might not change
your opinions and again we have very few
studies that um use actual politicians
and the studies that do use actual
politicians in Ireland where they've had
deliberative committees before often
show that politicians are kind of less
like ly to moderate and less likely to
change because they have different
concerns right they're very concerned
about public relations and the pr um PR
consequences of participating in these
deliberative committees but again does
that translate into actual policy change
or do they just fall back to partisan
lines there's you know uh there are less
kind of happy results when you use
politicians so these are the literatures
that we're speaking
to okay Denmark 19th century so that's
the constituent assembly obviously all
of our politicians are men because you
know you know
history um okay Denmark was kind of an
interesting case of democratization so
um Europe was facing a wave of
Revolutions in 1848 uh Denmark was at
War uh the Danish King saw the way the
wind was blowing and decided to seed the
country to create a Democratic Republic
he was called Frederick the Beloved
because of this so he did very well in
history but it's a bit unusual case that
Denmark didn't get kind of toppled by a
revolution like France did the Danish
King was like uhuh okay let's create a
constituent assembly you know I'll stay
a constitutional Monarch but let's let's
create a constitution right so this
happened in 1848 and the Constitution
was adopted in 1849 so we're talking
really about a year and kind of a
smaller period for deliberation and
voting and there's um a lot of uh
there's some good work on kind of roll
call voting in the case but um generally
there's not a lot of studies on this
case which maybe because it's not
conflict or War oriented it's it was a
peaceful transition so everyone studies
France and not
Denmark um okay so the party parties are
going to play an important role and this
is a great case because the parties were
weak but existing so they they stood on
ideological um uh platforms or they had
labels for themselves when they ran to
be elected to the Constitution assembly
but luckily for us the blocks are pretty
traditional 19th century Europe you know
the left was a movement of Rich Farmers
they were not peasants but they wanted
democracy they wanted representation the
national liberals were the ones that
actually pushed for the Constitution
these are kind of the merchants in the
cities they want democracy but they kind
of want to run it they don't want the
rich Farmers to run it so they're like
medium Pro democracy and then you have
the right which are aristocratic buddies
with the King everyone has accepted that
we need to have a democracy but there's
a spectrum on how inclusive how
Democratic how much the King has power
to really kind of dissolve the assembly
and so that's what they're going to be
fighting over in the
Constitution okay and parties were
parties institutions were new and weak
right so they said hey let's look at
what France did France had a Sol
solution for kind of an unstable
environment and that's how France did
their constitution um uh let's do that
and so um anti-democratic Elites they
were worried about kind of blocking
democracy so they decided to use
lotteries so they Ed these random
deliberative groups and the rationale
and we can see that from the
Parliamentary debate so why did they put
this rule in place it was to expose
members to crosscutting debate to make
people get into a room with other
parties other members that they didn't
know to let ideas flow better so exactly
the same rationals we have
today okay so our constituent assembly
has 157 um elected or King appointed
members five of them went off to be
minister so it ends up being 152 we have
five deliberative groups so they
deliberate in groups of 30 or 31 which
is relatively large but they stayed in
these groups the whole time right so
we're going to kind of exploit these
groups to see if over these kind of six
months there was learning they debated
the Constitution draft and then we have
the roll call votes in the general
assembly where they voted on each of
these parts of the Constitution again
three parties and then the King was kind
of in a background um the king actually
appointed deputies to make sure that
there were folks protecting his interest
because the election for the constituent
assembly went really left but because
the king interfered you basically have
equal numbers of each blocks across the
chamber okay so what we're trying to ask
using this case is do you know does
policy deliberation and randomly
assigned groups affect voting behavior
on the draft Constitution with the
hypothesis is that if these randomly
group randomly assigned groups expose
members to these new viewpoints we
should see behavioral change the way we
decide to um uh operationalize this is
by looking at the number of left-wing
deputies or here I'm going to show you
the Share of left-wing deputies in your
group with this idea that they were the
most democratic you know if you were a
liberal or a right-wing deputy and you
were exposed to more of these leftwing
deputies you would maybe move to closer
to them that is a choice that is a
substantive choice we also look at the
number of right-wing deputies right
because you might be affected by the
other tals yeah Kevin was Universal suff
was that was that on the table was that
yeah that some of the votes that we have
were the the the titling land
requirements for suffrage and so and it
and it works exactly like you think the
rich Farmers wanted inclusive suffrage
and then you know the right wanted like
only very very rich Elite yeah so they
have like a series of votes which um you
know spoiler alert the rich Farmers loss
yeah um okay so we use a lot of cool
historical data so we use the
Parliamentary records we use the roll
call voting um we go look to see whether
uh they these individual um
parliamentarians had served in politics
before whether they were nobility all
sorts of really cool Rich Micro Data if
you have questions I'm going to skip
over that Buton it's nice and again
we're going to look at 44 roll call
votes on the amendments to the
Constitution we coded these we went and
looked at the substance and we coded
these as pro-democratic or not and these
are suffrage whether the king can
dissolve parliament um you know we use
19 of them that are really really clear
like if you're voting for an increase in
who can stand for office you are
pro-democratic or not and there's um I
can go into details um if anyone has has
questions and then again our treatment
is a the member of this random group
composition the share of left
deputies okay and this is you can kind
of see the variation we're exploiting
right so here uh these are the party
blocks so blue is left yellow orange is
Center and right um is the or sorry red
is the right and then you have some uh
free Shooters Independence it's kind of
fun in Denmark they called them free
Shooters if you were independent but
they kind of do their own thing so
typically we're only looking at um the
blocks but you see variation right can
you see this Mouse yeah so here this
group has a very small proportion of
leftwing deputies this group has kind of
a plurality portion of left wi deputies
we're trying to see if deliberation in
this group versus this group namely the
number of left-wing pro-democracy people
in your group changes your
mind um okay and this is a legislative
vote panel data set um and again we're
exploiting the fact that uh the group
assignment was um
random okay so now to uh get to the
results so we first look at cohesion
this is just descriptive to see if uh if
you're debating with the same people so
this is kind of like if I if we randomly
um moved you guys all to tables and you
spent six months debating would Costas
and Dimitri you know vote with more
likely to vote with each other or would
this table vote with each other not
parties but your assigned group and so
one two 3 four five these are each of
the assigned group and the uh uh xaxis
is effectively time and this is a rice
index so the higher the rice index the
more cohesive you are and as you can see
nothing nothing mildly negative so it's
not the case that you you know form a
group identity with your deliberative
groups even though you're in these
groups every day debating these
Constitution you tend to vote kind of
however you want yeah Kenzie
hips go
between
thatth yeah so it's about six months so
it's kind of starts in January and then
ends in May and you'll see like if you
know for those of you who study kind of
parliamentary Behavior you'll see kind
of cluster so it's not like they had one
every week they did all the suffrage
ones and they debated for while and they
did all of the you know we kind of you
know you can look to see uh we don't
think that time is really you know
playing a huge role which is why it's
not you know it's an index as a vote not
like a weekly because they were kind of
three clusters right but good question
okay we see minor effects for party
blocks so again this was deliberative
group flat lines you know we'd expect it
to be positive um uh if if we thought
that there was a group identity uh here
we see kind of mildly positive again
overtime so like the left is a little
bit up center right this is also again
these were new parties that the
Democracy didn't exist yet they were
creating uh creating it but we see a
little bit more of an effect for um
parties than we do deliberative
groups okay and now results and so here
you're going to see um the dependent
variable we're trying to predict is pro
democracy voting and the I'm going to
use this I'm not going to move but I'm
going to use this this is the
coefficient we care about which is the
share of left deputies okay we're going
to look at this panel first two models
one with individual controls one with
not but again we're exploiting the
random assignment of the treatment
nothing nothing and pretty close to zero
so there's no effect of the number of
left deputies on your voting behavior
there is an effect of what party you're
in right so compared um uh to the left
so the left is the base case here uh the
center and right were less likely to
vote for democracy so that that follows
right so here what's this showing is
that the deliberative group is not
having effect while early partisanship
is if you concep ize this differently as
the number of right deputies so you
swing over to the other tail again we
have no effect and again you see the
left and some of the center are more
likely to vote for democracy but I'm
going to show you a difference which is
looking at heterogeneous treatment
effects because we would we would
imagine that you know if you're a
leftwing deputy the number of leftwing
deputies is not going to change you
because you're already with them so we
split them into what party you are so
this is only left deputies are they
affected by either the share of left
deputies or right deputies nope only
deputies nope only right deputies nope
okay so a lot of nope what does this
mean we do other robustness because
again we're kind of limited by it's a
small sample you know that's the
downside of historical cases the data we
have is the or the data I shown you is
the data we have we do do randomization
inference to see kind of How likely
these null results would be and it kind
of does support um our claims we do a
couple other things but generally we
don't have evidence using the historical
case that these deliberative groups were
significantly imp impacting these high
stakes votes
right and so what we think and what we
think that this um historical case can
teach us about modern-day lotteries so
we do find partisan effects and even
early partisan effects and again you
know if you're a political scientists
and you study how um deeply rooted
partisan identity is and the incentives
of politicians to represent their
constituents or just pursue their own
policy preferences while in office you
might see this in say yeah like why
would these deliberative groups have an
effect if they came into the
Constitution wanting to observe their
goals you know maybe maybe this is not
surprising um but it is important
because again this is a study of actual
politicians over a long period of time
debating something that was high Stak so
we think that this is a really nice
historical case to inform and teach us
about how politicians would would um
work with maybe lotteries today and
again you know we need to be a little
bit cautious although I think we need
more research in higher level bodies and
it's great to see all you practitioners
here I'm going to talk to you about this
later but finally and we'll get back to
this at the end of the panel um the lcy
literature doesn't know what to do with
parties right so at the very best they
say you know well they can exist as
extra parliamentary organizations
parties don't have to leave if we have a
uh a congress chosen entirely by Lottery
but it is the case that these
professional politicians with well-oiled
machines um and Dimitri's work actually
talks about this could still influence
politics and we we should assume that
they will still try to influence
politics and hybrid systems that combine
politicians and citizens these are going
to be powerful players with maybe uh
preferences that won't be as easy to
moderate doesn't mean we can't do it but
we need to be aware that at high levels
you know um citizens might be more
likely to update than
politicians um okay so I'm going to uh
conclude uh there um and uh take any
questions uh you might have about
lotteries about Denmark or just in
general en discussion do what you will
yeah
Kevin
thanks this is
Sugg I totally agree with you
about lot ofs Andy not really knowing
what to do with with parties um and I
wonderist um but I to what
I wonder I'm not loud enough okay um
it's good I can hear you great yes so um
and the I guess the tape does um right
so so so my question is basically about
representation right so I asked about
this before yeah um because I think one
of the things that might be happening
here is and I mean I think I've read a
lot about this uh that lot of cats I in
so far as they are thinking about
representation at all which I think some
there's there's a lot of division Within
within the debate about this yeah some
lats will say we are trying to like
representation has failed we're going to
a form of direct democracy that
circumvents representation altogether
because that was the problem of your
original conception of like the problem
is voters feel um that they're being
governed by disconnected Elites so what
we want to do is eliminate Elites um
that position there's been a lot of
pressure put on that position right uh
uh within the literature um are
colleague here at Yale alen landore has
kind of moved sort of away from that
position and toward a position that's
like no no no the randomly selected
citizens conceive of themselves as
Representatives but it's a different
kind of representation and so that's
what I would sort of want to suggest
here that maybe I mean one of the the
fault lines that's running through here
I think is that parties are simply
approaching or or are in a way based on
a completely different conception of
representation in democracies what is
representation it's electing more or
less ideological or programmatic groups
who are going to govern in line with
those with those uh with those promises
and lcy well we're going to have
ordinary people think about the issues
or something right it's like a again
they're sort of working on what exactly
that that means so like I said it's not
so much a question as a comment I wonder
to what extent though that you you know
you see this you could imagine seeing
elements of this play out if you do some
kind of substantive analysis of the
debates where it's like look I'm here to
represent the interests of the groups
that I'm a part of or the party as
opposed to oh yeah you know you make a
good point and so I'm gonna abandon my
party's position because we're here to
like deal with the issues in this
unmediated way I think that's more of
the conception that lats have had coming
out of the deliberative tradition and
that you talk about here right like when
you when you would expect people to
change their minds it's because there
are arriving into the the the decision
space with a different task are we
considering the issue substantively or
are we
bringing some kind of authorization with
us or something like that sorry no
that's a really great Point too and um
uh everyone should meet Theo so Theo's
uh postto associated with the um uh the
Democratic Innovations program and works
with Len uh Theo is doing a conference
and studying exactly that right because
they've found increasingly even if
you're chosen by Lottery citizens feel
like they have a job to do like they
were chosen to again represent represent
something and it's kind of interesting
because are they chosen you know like a
politician elected in a district has you
know very clear mandates like schools
stuff for that District those are the
people that they're going to elect him
versus someone who's chosen by Lottery
they feel like they need to be
representative but sometimes it varies
by person so they need to represent
their class they need to represent their
geographic area but it's much it's much
more expansive but there still is a a a
level of responsibility and so that's
what Theo is working on so everyone go
talk to Theo he'll be here um um at some
point so I think that's true um and
what's interesting is so like in the
historical cases you know we're looking
like Bren and I are looking at a a wide
range and what's interesting is like the
idea of representation also changes
right so like from ancient Greece to
then 19th century Europe like 19th
century Europe politicians they were
like well I know best I'm going to do
these but these Elites who thought that
you know we were kind of in the era of
should should citizens even be involved
in this right so they had an idea of a
mandate but the Mandate was you know I
I'm Elite I I can decide this for the
people but there still was kind of this
idea of representation and um we had so
um uh the the one of the policy makers
that was instrumental in setting up the
the Belgian committees was here a couple
weeks ago Jonathan mosic super super
interesting work um and he was talking
about also Al it depends on the
politician so some politicians that have
participated in these deliberative
committees um uh and the politicians can
self- select in which is important so
the citizens are chosen randomly but the
politicians who work on the issue or who
want to do that self- select so again
the selection effects so and
theoretically these politicians would be
the one who are interested in this want
to learn um some politicians are you
know uh uh they believe in the cause
they believe in this type of democratic
Innovation they believe in the structure
they believe they can learn something so
they go into it being open to updating
and open to listening to Citizens and
they said other politicians are doing it
for the photo op basically and so that's
not a politician versus citizen that's
variation within individual politicians
and what's interesting is that in
Belgium uh it's the the green party or
at least the Jonathan was working with
the green party so the climate the
liberal like you know those politicians
really believe in the cause and are kind
of open to it while other politicians
doing other topics are are less so some
of this might not be a a levels it might
be individual variation like you know
convince politicians that this is a good
exercise maybe they will be less likely
to dominate the discussion because
that's they uh surveyed um the citizens
after the Belgian experiment and some of
the citizens were like yeah politicians
like to talk and they like to dominate
the conversation and they are skilled
right if you think about juries right
you know some folks are you know or
professors or maybe often we're on fewer
juries because is our job to convince
people that we're right maybe that would
not be great in like a a jury system um
but yeah great questions Kevin yeah
Demetri
um do you have sense of how much
pressure M of parlamentary uh randomly
selected groups were from their
respective parties to maintain the party
L how much that might have affected the
outcomes you're observing yeah so what's
interesting is that because you know you
look at like the they were weak parties
where they had kind of labels and we
assume you know like the historical
record it seems to indicate that they
did kind of like caucus and especially
like the king appointed deputies kind of
had a different mandate right but the
problem is that there weren't um uh
Records are kind of like the historical
data is a bit so like were there party
meetings did they meet by the water
cooler did they meet in the tavern and
conceptualize themselves as a party um
there wasn't any kind of um uh whipping
or sticks and carrots that a party
institution could use to make members
vote it was more kind of ideological
kind of preferences and if you think
about like kind of creel's where's the
party like at least you know parties
didn't have a lot so anything that kept
them together would have been either
shared preferences because they want all
the stuff for themselves or kind of
these networks where they all knew each
other and they did and you can see um if
you do roll call scaling like um it's
the three groups are visible across the
additional votes that are not pro
democracies because they were fighting a
war so there's military votes and they
were cohesive like they were doing stuff
um kind of together and there wasn't you
know um there wasn't a lot of things
that parties didn't have access to
anything because this was just a
constituent assembly but past that we're
not sure to what extent there were like
extra parliamentary meetings to help
coordinate Behavior yeah do you have a
uh do you have any evidence of like
pamplets party pamplets being put out at
that time articulating you know a party
position or articulating a particular
platform these pamplets being written
Maybe by activists or by people who are
influential with the party leadership
anything that would suggest attempts to
maintain a particular Party Line in the
broader discursive context so the only
thing that I remember is or the the
closest thing to that would be so I told
you the constituent assembly went to the
left right so the they had this election
for this constituent assembly you know
electing these deputies and the rich
Farmers the society for the friends of
the peasants mobilized so they had kind
of they had soap boxes they were like oh
we want our interest represent that's
why they did so well in the election and
the king and the elites were like where'
you come from wait turnout we need to
turnout like these peasants have never
turned or these farmers in rural areas
have never turned out before and that's
why the king had to get involved and be
like well you actually won the election
but here are my people let's like even
the scales but it was on the left it was
on the ones that would be the most
pro-democratic kind of early and exactly
like you think like the codra parties
and the extra the Grassroots parties
like the reason the left it but they
were they were the most in terms of of
pushing for the Democracy while the
other two parties like you know a lot of
historical record were much looser like
they wanted to protect their own power
but they were used to being in power so
the idea that you had to mobilize
totally shocked them in in the beginning
yeah but we could look at that more
that's actually a good that's a good
idea and you can do text analysis with
um all like the debates and stuff we
have not um but there's um now OCR and
digitization is getting better so you
can actually look to see you know if
you're not if voting is not the best
outcome to measure how else could you
measure you could maybe measure speeches
so maybe they have to vote the way they
were going to but if you have any
evidence of changing their mind maybe
the language they use changes uh as a
function of this group but that would
require a bit more thinking like how to
measure them yeah Kevin yeah so in the
Irish case right in the first one that
they had was a mix citizens and
politicians right and uh it was
precisely issues that split the parties
right so whatever the official position
was of the party the whole point of why
they were kicking the decisions over to
the to the citizens assembly was because
they didn't really have unified
positions that split that that neatly
divided the parties they were kind of
like we don't want to make this decision
about abortion we don't want to make
this I I forget which one if it was
marriage or equality or abortion the
first one but they we don't want to make
this decision it splits our parties um
so it' be interesting to see there might
be variation
inh and then that's also kind of like a
third party like oh we're divided what
do the citizens say you know if they
would if they had done that for brexit
before the UK parties made the biggest
mistake of this generation like maybe we
would not be maybe UK people would not
be in the the state you're in yeah
Brenda Brenda can you get the mic
where's thank you hi um I'm Brena from s
um so one thing I would add to that is
that the the picture that um you didn't
show today but that we also have um
about the roll call scaling shows that
these parties great yeah that's the one
yeah um shows that these parties are not
clearly distinct and apart right so
there's some overlap between some
individuals and that's really good
evidence for the fact that you don't
have these uh parties really um um imple
like imposing their party
lines
yeah
Christian hey U I'm Christian Griff from
the University of Southern California
and you mentioned upfront about the
election into the deliberative processes
and choosing citizens broadly as more
representative as you as you've defined
it um what were the other ways to pick
people like did they choose on
competence or expertise or who who who
the parties wanted like can you just
talk a little bit more about the the
selection in when it wasn't truly random
of all citizens yeah I mean so in some
of these early cases I mean like
elections weren't like they were today
like sometimes they were indirect or the
elections were only you know if you
think about like the the British cases
the Victorian vote byy you know so most
of the time when we're comparing um
Lotto critic selection like the Baseline
would be um election if we're talking
about like choosing um individuals to
sit in a representative body once we're
in the assembly typically so like if you
didn't choose um who uh was on the
budget committee using this kind of
two-step procedure it would be parties
right it' be party groups and of those
parties it would be Elites in the
parties like the party leaders or like
the high level people and actually we
show in the French case that parties you
know they use this Lottery brace
procedure to choose the most powerful
committee like the one that controlled
the money and then once parties got
strong they dismantled it and then went
back to parties choose who go on the
budget committee and you can see that
like the general representation of the
budget committee like the average you
know what who was on it like where they
were coming from their background um
drops right so Elites go back on as soon
as parties can choose now there's kind
of a larger question here which is you
know the the idea that parties can use
these uh committees as you know sticks
and carrots that might be good for
parties like using random selection for
committees takes that away from parties
it also takes the ability of people to
develop expertise so there are tradeoffs
actually either it's not we don't think
parties are bad sometimes parties can
use this to like build seniority but it
is the case at least in the European
cases that we study that you know we're
kind of like the the
the middle class Deputy was on the
budget committee and then once parties
got it it went back to being Elites um
but one thing that I'm looking at um and
I will end on this point um is uh so you
know when we're thinking about how take
up and this is I'm working on a survey
experiment to kind of tease this out but
if we're thinking about takeup so I
randomly invite you all to a Citizens
assembly you know I and we make sure
that there's um you know female from
Texas you know they say no we find
another female from Texas they say yes
yes right if there is an unobservable
that has nothing to do with the random
sampling that makes the one that said no
not liking democracy kind of a dissident
and the one that said yes just already
predisposed to like citizens assembly
sort to have different um outcomes um I
mean that might happen that you know
from a practical side like we can't you
know control all of the unobservables
that would make people want to give up
their weekend to talk about climate but
interpreting our findings we need to
understand more about this selection
because it's not the case the invitation
is random the takeup is not random and
the more we understand takeup and what
I'm looking at is actually polarization
so in cases like the us or even the UK
you know you might think it's fine to
discuss kind of Municipal budgeting but
if I know that I'm going to talk with a
bunch of uh Co out partisans like the
opposing partisans about black lives
matter for a weekend there are some
people that would say no I don't want to
do that because I I'm effective part
polarization is so high and so
understanding that can help us like you
know keep the representative benefits of
the random sampling but make sure that
we know kind of um our pools and stuff
yeah quickly Kevin yeah so I I want
somebody do a study somebody do a study
please looking at um how many people
they need when they have stratified uh
uh requirements like we need these many
people who don't have a college degree
and so forth I want to know how many
people did they have to ask what's the
denominator yes for the different
categories right because and you have
that and like you know I talked to Helen
about this like Iceland you know the
people who wanted to do it were
predominantly male and educated other
places you know uh and think about
inclusivity uh like Belgium did paper
mailings right so they they sent a
letter and I asked like how' the youth
do like how you know would a youth get
uh and they said they actually had like
pretty good youth participation but like
this is just like surveying how you how
you recruit actually influences who
participates like quite a bit um anyway
thank you very much we're going to now
move to federa who's going to talk about
again historical Collective governance
so fed if you want to come on up and
then again coffee
and